Now, sometimes when people are trying to decide whether a word is good or bad,...
...they don't really have a good reason.
So they say something like, "Because grammar!"
But that makes no sense to me.
Words are great.
We should have more of them.
I want you to make as many new words as possible.
And I'm gonna tell you six ways that you can use to make new words in English.
The first way is the simplest way.
Basically, steal them from other languages.
Linguists call this borrowing, but we never give the words back,...
...so I'm just gonna be honest and call it stealing.
We usually take words for things that we like, like delicious food.
We took "kumquat" from Chinese, we took "caramel" from French.
We also take words for cool things like "ninja," right?
We took that from Japanese,...
....which is kind of a cool trick 'cause ninjas are hard to steal from.
So, another way that you can make words in English...
...is by squishing two other English words together.
This is called "compounding."
Words in English are like Lego:...
...if you use enough force, you can put any two of them together.
We do this all the time in English.
Words like "heartbroken," "bookworm," "sand castle," all are compounds.
Another way that you can make words in English is kind of like compounding,...
...but instead you use so much force when you squish the words together...
...that some parts fall off.
So these are blend words, like "brunch" is a blend of "breakfast" and "lunch."